I have something very exciting to
announce today Pat I have been sworn to
secrecy on this for months as it has
been developing and I am now cleared to
tell you that the David Pakman show is
part of a select group of podcasts which
are going to be part of Pandora's new
podcast offerings Pandora is this huge
music discovery and streaming service
many of you I know use it already they
have decided to jump into the fray with
podcasting they're going to launch
podcasts sometime in the next four to
six weeks and this is just going to be
huge for the David Pakman show and for
our podcast we are already on Spotify
iTunes I Heart Radio stitcher and
getting on Pandora is absolutely massive
for us sometime in December I am told
you will be able to subscribe to and
listen to the David Pakman show podcast
on Pandora this is again an invite-only
curated group of podcasts and what else
can I say Pat this is just great for the
show yeah I'm actually kind of nervous
do you want me to change anything about
the production here on my end how about
my my my tone and tenor on the show do
we have to adjust in language police to
fit
Pandora's platform oh yeah we're going
to be doing all sorts of language
policing of Pat and there's going to be
there's gonna be actually a list of
banned words Keurig is going to be one
of them feral cats is not a phrase that
will ever be allowed on the program
again and there's gonna be a whole list
of banned words for Pat now that we are
on Pandora
no I'm kidding but listen sign up to be
notified you can use if you're watching
on youtube there's a link in the video
description if you are listening you can
sign up to be notified about these new
podcast offerings on Pandora the website
is Pandora podcast beta dot splash that
com Pandora podcast beta splash dot-com
this is uh this is all good for what I
believe are going to be the biggest two
years in politics
since the David Pakman show went on the
air these next two years I've been
talking about that now for a week since
the midterms and possibly the biggest
two years politically in my lifetime at
least maybe American politics at this
time a lot is riding on the next few
years membership patreon subscribe to
the Pandora beta subscribe on YouTube
anything all of it all much appreciated